leave them the hell alone a very large
proportion of kids with gender dysphoria
grow up and are homosexual yes but that
certainly means is that the vast
majority and it might be as high as 80
percent of the kids who are being
convinced now that they inhabit the
wrong bodies and are being surgically
mutilated in a permanent terrible manner
the overwhelming majority of them are
gay when I was growing up or 10 years
old I was playing with GI Joe and
Transformers and I liked war and battle
and all of those boy thought of things
now there are plenty of gay kids that
are growing up that like Barbie or they
like you know dressing up or whatever
that might be in today's world the
teacher at the school or the
administrator or the gender expert or
whatever would probably be coaching them
towards saying that they were trans
where they would have left someone like
me alone so in an odd sense the trans
movement is extremely anti-gay there are
gay people who are very effeminate but
they still happen to be men